angry scenes in peru's capital
protesters say the judge's decision to
pardon former president alberto fujimori
is an insult teodosia
says she will not forgive or forget
he has to pay his full 25 year sentence
he has killed many innocent people
fujimori is a murderer
fukimori who governed between 1990 and
2000 remains a polarizing figure in the
country some peruvians lot him for
defeating the shining path rebel
movement others want him held to account
for human rights violations carried out
under his leadership
giselle ortiz's brother is one of the
students killed in a massacre
we are outraged the constitutional court
now frees fujimori a right that does not
correspond to him and tramples on the
right to justice that we have as family
members
the court's decision on thursday
restored a humanitarian pardon granted
in 2017 by then president pedro pablo
kuczynski the following year the
country's supreme court overturned that
decision and sent the former strongman
back to jail to serve the remainder of
his sentence
some experts say this latest decision to
pardon fukimori contravenes
international human rights treaties
his family and supporters say that
fujimori's health has deteriorated
during his incarceration and believe he
shouldn't have to die behind bars
for him he hasn't complied with part of
his sentence he hasn't acknowledged his
crimes he hasn't paid reparations or
asked the victims for forgiveness or
contributed to solve some of the crimes
where people remain disappeared
some critics say they wouldn't oppose
fukhimari's release if he admitted to
his crimes
if there was a public expression of
forgiveness to the victims that would
change the situation a lot we have been
waiting for it for many years but it is
not going to happen because he and his
defense continue to say that fujimori is
innocent
defense lawyers have asked the
inter-american court for human rights to
review the decision
for now fukimori awaits his release with
supporters celebrating the man they
consider a savior during pedus civil war
and others who expect the international
court to say the decision by pedus court
is no mariana sanchez al-jazeera lima
peru